thank you very much for having me here
thank you the c-span for for coming and
I want to tell you you've got a heck of
a Dean here I've known Mike as he
mentioned for a long long time and he
taught me a great deal about writing as
a matter of fact the thing that he
taught that was most important is you've
got to put passion in your writing
you can't just be sort of a boring
person
you gotta like let it rip and he
actually does that and I have to tell
you about one thing that blew my mind he
once wrote a book review about this
philosopher Hegel who if you think I'm
going to put you to sleep you should try
reading Hegel and this book review ended
with a passionate love scene between
being and becoming which is something
this guy Hegel wrote wrote about so if
you can write with passion and turn a
philosopher's dry words into a love
scene well you you can write with
passion so I've never forgotten that
like okay we're dealing with tonight a
let me see if I can get this going here
why write a book like this I why write a
book about earning a million dollars an
hour what I was trying to do are three
things I'm trying to raise the most
fundamental questions about how economic
value is produced by Wall Street elites
what is it what is it that they do
that's so valuable the second thing I
want to look at is one of the root
causes of the increasing inequality in
our economy it's it's the the gaps
between the super-rich and everybody
else is growing where's that coming from
and I wanted to also the third thing was
to kind of revisit the economic crash
that happened in 2008 to see if we can
get a deeper understanding of what
happened because I I must admit when I
wrote the book looting of America I was
kind of naive I didn't realize what they
were really up to so this book is taking
us into a new territory okay let me
start by asking you a question
what's a fair hourly wage for you what
are you hoping to earn when you become
journeyman what's a good hourly wage oh
by the way I forgot to tell you that
that's my fee for tonight so thank you
very much Dean Merrill what's it what's
a good wage for ya 56 dollars an hour
what do you think 60 you'd like to get
60 okay let's say it's let's let's go
for 56 to 60 bucks an hour why is
someone going to pay you $60 an hour why
yes oh okay because of the skills you
have to do the job it's not just the
skills you have right it's actually
applying the skills you have to do the
job so why are they going to give you
money what's in it for them what okay
there's risk involved what else write
the cert you're providing services to
them to make profit yeah
right you work hard to develop your
skills to go through this whole
apprenticeship program including a
couple years of college at the minimum
what else y'all right you're producing a
building you like it you know your
commercial electricians putting up a
building yeah you're making money for
them as well yes you're producing a high
quality product that has incredible
values of the people that are hiring you
care enough okay so the mystery we're
going to try to figure out to this
afternoon is what do they these things
called hedge funds produce but before we
get there let's look at some of the
occupations in this country and that
have the highest incomes and see what it
looks like on an hourly basis let's
start with here are the ten that by the
way the first chapter this book we put
together we look at the wealthiest
occupations in the country so here are
the top 10 movie stars from 2010 takes a
while to put a book into production so
those are the latest numbers that we had
you can see Leonard DiCaprio leads the
list his income was 77 million dollars
you divided by 2080
right number of hours you guys work in a
year and you get to his hourly income
was 37 thousand and $19 the the average
for that group was twenty one thousand
two hundred ninety-eight dollars an hour
the average for the top ten as you can
see includes you know Seinfeld and Depp
and Adam Sandler and the bottom list is
Angelina Jolie right they make a good
living so how what do they do
to make all that money how come they get
paid so much
skill that provides profit people hiring
them for sure absolutely a skill
provides a profit for the people hiring
them yes there's that they have a lot of
bargaining power anything else yes there
you go they sell movie tickets so you
got and what's behind the movie tickets
there's a really simple exchange here we
like watching them so we'll pay to watch
them right and in exchange they get
money we get entertainment we get
pleasure watching them so it's something
we all understand do we be grudge them
make it a bit a lot of money but you
know think it's kind of fun to watch
them right we all keep going we don't go
on strike and stay out of the movie
theaters we like we're not protesting
over the $10 tickets we seem to go okay
so let's take a look at this now at the
top occupations in the country let's
start at the bottom this was from 2010
you can see the bank top bank insurance
CEOs they were like roughly eight
thousand dollars an hour and we go up
the lawyers authors by the way I did not
make the top ten in 2010 I'm working on
it for 2013 when Mike gives me the check
I'll get very close got the movie stars
you got your top athletes by the way
that would be Tiger Woods was number one
then top CEOs musicians top celebrities
in general like Oprah was number one on
that list I was very surprised to find
out that the top of this whole group
were movie directors they make more than
movie stars I guess they put the whole
thing together
makes sense so what we did is we put to
see their hourly income and then there's
this thing called hedge fund managers
that are like off-the-charts eight
hundred and forty two thousand seven
hundred eighty eight dollars an hour
that's a lot of money that's forty times
with the movie stars make 40 times what
do they do tell me
we don't know what they do do we we
don't know you go ask anybody what they
do and you're gonna get a stare I don't
know are we paying to watch them perform
hit a golf ball we don't know what they
do but they're making way off the list
right so let's take a look a little
closer what is a hedge fund Hut this is
a college right so you got to get a
multiple-choice test you're here your
options a a wholesale garden supply
business that specializes in growing and
trimming hedges be a mutual fund where
anyone can invest that hedges against
tough times see an investment fund for
the super-rich and large institutions by
the way where you need to where you need
at least a million dollars in wealth in
order to invest a B or C all right it is
C I didn't make the test hard enough
I'll talk to your teachers about that
afterwards okay so that's what it is and
it's actually for more than just wealthy
investors you've got pension funds that
want to get in on the action
a lot of the large banks want to invest
in these funds and these funds are kind
of very interesting the person who runs
them gets two percent of the money off
the top and then 20 percent of the
profits so the question then becomes is
what do they invest in how do they play
their game well the top hedge fund guy
in 2010 made 2.4 million dollars an hour
in 2010 that's as much as the average
family makes in 47 years think about
that one hour work you go to work today
one hour would equal a family's income
average family for a lifetime
forty-seven years so if you're going to
do that in our economic system you
better be producing a whole lot of value
for the economy all those things you
just mentioned before about you know
building something that will last for a
long time and it's worth 10 times more
when you're done because of all the
great work you did and the skill you put
into it and
the service it provides all that stuff
you talked about it better be true here
or we got a big problem so let's explore
that question oh there's another one the
top 25 hedge funds that year by the way
earned as much as six hundred and fifty
eight thousand teachers who teach 13
million kids just giving you a sense of
how big these guys were okay let me let
me put another dimension of this puzzle
I want you to get very curious about
what these people do let me make you
even more curious
in 2010 the top hedge fund made as much
money as Apple Apple has approximately
seven hundred thousand employees and
contractors all over the world the top
hedge fund had under a hundred employees
so with under 100 employees they Purdue
they supposedly produced as much
economic value as Apple with seven
hundred thousand employees what did they
do what did they do for all that money
we ought to be feeling their impact
right we ought to they ought to be doing
something great absolutely stupendous
for the American economy
so where does all that money come from
how is it possible for that much money
to exist I mean you're hoping to get
your 50 $60 an hour and you're well on
your way to doing that and you'll be
worth every penny where does all their
money come from any questions so far who
are you with me yeah still awake okay
good most of you anyway all right I want
you there's only one chart in this whole
talk that you've got to grasp and hang
on to and if you do this chart will do
you well for the rest of your life what
we're looking at here that top purple
line is a measure of US productivity you
heard the word productivity at work and
people talking about productivity you
know how much output you put out they
want you to get certain number of jobs
done well if you measure that for the
whole economy when it comes down to is
it measures the level of organization
technique technology skill that exists
in the whole economy
and what's amazing about the American
economy is that every year in the last
65 years every year except five years
productivity went up in other words the
amount the way they measure it is they
take the total amount of what we produce
and divide it by the number of hours it
takes to produce it
now how much it costs for the number of
hours so we were able to produce more
and more per hour every year and even
the years that it didn't go up it it
didn't go down by very much that's dedi
line measures the wealth of the United
States up up up
that's why we've got so much stuff
because and you've probably already seen
it in your short careers that new
techniques come in new right you get to
use a different kind of a switching box
or something you get to do the job
faster a little bit better more
efficiently not only faster but
sometimes actually even better right so
that's part of productivity well between
World War two the end of World War two
and through the mid-1970s every time
productivity went up the average workers
wage also went up in real terms after
inflation and I don't think too many
people here are my age but if you grew
up when I grew up in the 50s and 60s you
would have noticed my parents were
working-class immigrant people and their
standard of living we live you know
little box house out in the burbs and
you could see that their standard of
living was going up every year a little
bit you know they got a few more you
know air conditioners for the house and
then they went they even went on a
vacation you know to someplace they went
out like a cruise for the first time in
their lives like in the 60s they were
able to send me to a private university
they couldn't my older sister because
they didn't have the money then that was
going on throughout the economy and the
real wage went from about $400 a week
after you take care of inflation in
today's dollars went up to seven hundred
forty six dollars a week that's average
for working people across the economy
then you notice something weird happen
the two lines split apart wages start
going down productivity keeps going up
and that's something quite amazing
happened when those two lines split
apart any idea any ideas come to mind
yeah internet comes later actually comes
later comes in the 80s but there was
some technology involved but it's funny
these two lines in Europe don't split
apart like this and they have the same
technology here something special happen
any ideas
yeah uh maybe yeah some uh actually it
started under a Democrat hey hey any
other ideas
yes well stock mark had been around a
long time so I that was one piece
declining unionism yeah there were some
stock market crashes in there there were
and there was some turbulence going on
in the economy yes uh yeah there was
definitely some of that definitely that
yeah greed now it's very interesting
that you should say that I actually
tried to do some research on the history
of greed and I think it's been with us
for a long time
so the question because what societies
can do is contain it or let it go right
is something that can move deregulation
there's there and let me let me talk
about deregulation you're talking about
by the way from a business point of view
what's the number one regulation that
business wants to get rid of take a
guess number one minimum wage well yeah
if you're low income business true but
in general when business says we have to
get rid of regulation what do you think
they're thinking about the most taxes he
onions see this ought you're smart
you're the first audience that's guessed
that what's not yes it was the guess it
was knowledge who is your professor very
well done well done
I that you unions are the biggest
regulation that a business faces right
because you're right there you know
government regulation they can kind of
get around with the unions right there
so one of the pieces they they want to
deregulate though what happened was the
economy was getting kind of screwed up
during that period and uh we got our two
lines up again but there we go yeah
there was the there was a very turbulent
period of the economy and a bunch of
economists and policy makers got
together they said you know what we need
to new a new theory of how to run this
economy and here's what we should do we
should deregulate which is unions but
also we should deregulate finance
especially finance finance if you
deregulate them they're going to do some
good things so let's let's make it tough
for unions deregulate finance get rid of
taxes especially on the on the rich
people because what's going to happen is
you put all that together and they're
going to invest it and you're going to
get a boom and all boats are going to
rise that was the theory and so they put
that into practice there and they wanted
to the gentleman that mentioned the
brother mentioned greed yeah they want
to put greed to work for the
Arkan economy we're going to make greed
work for us and we we did as you can see
productivity really took off but the
wages didn't in the gap between those
two lines had to go somewhere so where
did it go
the only chart I could find anywhere
that looks like this one is this one
note kind of the same they split apart
they're together you know what this is
this is the wages in the financial
sector versus everything else
Wall Street wages versus wages in
industry your wages average the two were
together like in the other picture then
they once deregulation takes place a few
years later this is 1980 the wages on
Wall Street shoot up like a rocket boom
right and that's so that's like in the
mid 70s and now the lines split apart in
1980s the money goes up to Wall Street
this answers the question of how do
these hedge funds have so much money to
even play with because this theory of
deregulation and tax cuts came in and
once you deregulate Wall Street you can
expect incredible things to happen and
they did okay so that's our little
investment boom this is the plan that
split the lines any questions on this
yes forgive me actually it didn't slow
down but it didn't really move either
what really happened looks like was just
well actually
well let me I'm glad you mentioned that
let me make two points that I needed to
make the first is the difference between
those two lines this year is something
like three trillion dollars the average
wage would have been eleven hundred and
seventy one dollars a week the average
you guys be looking at 100 an hour the
average would be eleven seventy one if
the World War two trend continued where
productivity would be shared on a very
consistent basis with working people so
yes it doesn't it doesn't like go
vertical that's what goes vertically on
Wall Street okay let's move on here
here's the decline of unions what they
wanted to see happen happen they wanted
to get rid of that deregulation and down
it goes here's what happened in the
banking industry that these are the top
six banks as a percent of the whole
economy jumps from fourteen point eight
percent to 62 percent so Wall Street got
more concentrated and bigger oh yeah
sure
hey once you deregulate you can do
whatever you want they used to not be
able to have all these banks merge you
couldn't have a bank that operated in
more than one state yeah now you've got
Citibank and Chase and Bank America all
over the country and there's only a few
of them left okay the other thing that
happened of course was the richest
people got a lot richer in 1973 before
the two lines split apart eight percent
of the total income of the country went
to the top one percent believe me there
was still rich people when I was growing
up and they weren't us I mean there were
plenty of rich people around now it's
gotten kind of crazy 23 percent of all
the income goes to the top one percent
almost three times as much thanks to
that deregulation plan okay this is one
I thought you'd like this is original
data here we took the top 100 CEOs in
the country
and I compared it to the average wage of
a worker in 1970 for every one dollar a
worker earned the CEO top on our CEOs
are $45 as those lines split apart now
the top CEO guy by 2006 was earning
seventeen hundred and twenty three
dollars now do you think that they got
that much smarter that quickly right
because did their skill get so much
greater during that period that's the
question to consider but it sure matches
our line splitting apart for every
dollar that you earn they aren't they
went from $45 to seventeen hundred and
twenty-three in 20 in a 36 years that's
quite a change okay so how to hedge
funds how do these not garden supply
places how do these investment funds
actually make money I'm going to give
you one technique and if you master this
technique you can go get a job on Wall
Street I'm telling you this is this is
the craziest thing I ever came across
are you ready for this yeah no oh you
want me to just I can go on to a
different secret I don't have to tell
you this one all right you want this one
okay let's go let's go do it
the trick is you've got to create
something that's designed to fail and
then you can collect the insurance on it
so it's the equivalent of you going to
work right wiring it so it's going to
burn down within six months and then you
take an insurance policy out out on the
building so you can collect how long you
think you'd last if you did that not too
long but that's what we're going to get
into ever here are these words these are
called financial innovations that hedge
funds were a big part of mortgage backed
securities collateralized debt
obligations CDO squared credit default
swaps synthetic CDOs these are the terms
that they use and they're there believe
me
when I first saw these I my eyes glazed
over oh my god I bought a textbook on
one of them cost me $90
I read two pages and it was all math and
I had to either put the book down I
couldn't I couldn't deal with like I
couldn't get past two pages worst $90
I've ever spent
okay here's what we're going to be
talking about
that's the housing boom if you look at
that line start with the graph I have
only starts in 1987 but if we went back
all the way to here back to like 1850
the line would more or less be flat and
this is uh taking a care inflation
everything else this is the cost of
housing back through time it more or
less is constant and then something
incredible happened a decade ago and it
shot through the roof and then crashed
so this is the economic crash housing
prices hit levels as you probably
experienced or heard like never before
and then boom it goes down and I'm going
to give you a hint tonight about how
that happened least I'm going to try did
someone bring the champagne okay uh here
are the basics and you got to stop me if
this doesn't make any sense to you
here's what they did you ever hear what
you don't want to subprime mortgages you
know what these garbage mortgages are
you know where they give you a you're
not qualified but they'll give you the
mortgage anyway and then the interest
rate starts off really low and then it
jumps up and they say don't worry you
can sell your house in a couple years
and what balloon that's one of the
versions but they basically are looking
for people who don't really qualify for
regular thirty-year conventional
mortgage and they do these subprime
mortgages so here is their trick you
gather up a thousand subprime mortgages
right and they're all they're supposed
to pay interest and principal every
month you take the interest you pour it
into a bottle one place that bottle is
all the interest now all of these
mortgages are not going to fail at the
same time that matter of fact
historically ninety percent of people
and high-risk mortgage is paid ten
percent with default
so what you do is you put all the
interest rates together all the interest
money all that income and you these
wineglasses those are securities like
bonds and you set up a system where you
pour out the wine the champagne to the
top rose first then the middle row then
the bottom row and you say the top row
bonds get paid first so no matter what
happens if you have 20% foreclosures or
30% you're going to pay the top people
first so if you buy that bond you're
going to be okay right you're going to
be fine you're going to get your
interest rate you're going to get a very
good deal you're with me so far so they
took that to the rating agencies they
got triple-a ratings which meant they
were as good as buying a government bond
no problem
well the middle and they gave him a nice
interest rate too because it was junk ba
it's junk mortgages underneath so
they're paying a high interest rate
people say oh that's good you know
eventually they'll pay a high interest
rate so you're going to get a nice
interest rate return they sold those
things like hotcakes at top row they
sold them all over the world the next
row those were a little riskier right
because you only get paid after the top
guys get paid so the next row was a
little harder to sell and the bottom row
that's the gamblers like home tranches
you buy the bottom security you get
twenty thirty percent return but you're
the first to get wiped out if the
mortgages start to default so that's
called the mortgage-backed security so
what do you think they so and they had
no problem selling the top row and of
course once they start selling up more
people buying houses and they're getting
cheap mortgages and then they're selling
them to Wall Street who are packaging
them up like this and selling them it's
like a conveyor belt it's like an
assembly line
of mortgages you're with me what do you
do you guys are smart and gals what do
you do if you can't sell the ones in the
middle row what do you do with them you
know
what well let's say you can't send up
cell the middle one discount and that's
possible what else what else what could
you do with them what how do you do that
this guy he's auditioning for a Wall
Street job how do you do that you
package them into the other row there
you go here we go got what keep your eye
on these two what they when they
couldn't sell the middle row they would
take all the middle rows and package
them together create a new wine bottle
and start the process all over again so
now the wine bottle is filled with the
stuff that goes into the middle rows and
guess what so they started the whole
thing over again that's called a clowder
lies debt obligation now you've got
10,000 underlying junk mortgages put
together and guess what when they did
they Porter poured the line out again
starting at the top working it down when
they got done with it they went to a
rating agency guess what happened Triple
A rating once again for the top so now
just think about the miracle that was
created this is like the fish in the
loaves right you took the middle row
that was it you couldn't sell you
packaged them all together and you got
yourself another triple a set of
mortgages to sell up security to spell
which they then did all over the world
oh not yet not yet not yet not yet
now what do you do with the middle row
what do you do with the middle row you
still having trouble selling the middle
row just like the last time only now
it's even more dangerous what do you do
same thing they did it one more time
that's called the CDOs squared okay now
this is work it and guess what they got
triple-a ratings for the top row again
so now you sold the mortgage-backed
securities which had a chance to succeed
the junk that you couldn't sell from
that you package them got and got by the
way it's about 70 percent of them that
get the Triple A ratings you got seventy
percent three times pretty good pretty
good now here's where the hedge funds
come in so by now you the stock market
is having the housing prices are going
straight up right this is this is big
banks big banks this is being done by
your goldman sachs and your citigroup
and your JP Morgan Chase and your joint
your bank and they're they're the ones
that are doing this they have the they
have the customers they can off and on
and they have the ability to warehouse
all the in you know all the legal stuff
and get it together but guess what that
became too difficult too hard they were
running out of subprime mortgages there
weren't enough dead people to give
mortgages to which is what they were
doing by the way in Las Vegas and a guy
who did it for this country country when
I came over was countrywide or not
actually a guy who was engaging in fraud
who was an employee of one of these
mortgage companies actually got rewarded
as like the Employee of the Year for all
his sales even after he was caught after
he was caught he was rewarded so this
was big business here's where it gets
wild they were running out of mortgages
so they decided to do this synthetically
they could create the same things
through a series of bets called credit
default swaps I can't explain to you
right now exactly how they did it but it
Matt do you guys know fantasy sports do
you know how fantasy sports works you
don't own the players right but you can
still bet on them you have teams based
on football players you select and you
can have right you don't own the players
well they figured out how to do that as
well they did this whole thing again as
if they own them but they didn't own
them they put literally they set the
same thing up as a series of debts
fantasy mortgage fantasy finance exactly
they played the same game they looked at
they said pretend you own these
mortgages in Las Vegas and these
mortgages in New York and these mortgage
in Florida and let's see what happens to
them and we'll set the same thing up
again it's too complicated to explain
but trust me they did it and here's
where the here's where the hedge funds
came in yeah
creating insurance without insurance
well they created insurance in the
oddest way here's what they did to make
that bit to make those bet work bets
work the people that bought let's say
the top row there they get the insurance
premiums from someone who is betting
that those things main won't work out
forever
so they there's literally like an
insurance company that they become the
insurance company and the person paying
the insurance is the hedge fund and so
it's like a bet I'm betting that my team
is going to win and you're betting that
my team is going to lose it's it's it's
really that simple but here's where it's
not so simple the hedge funds
unbeknownst to the people that were
buying these securities the hedge funds
went out and found the worst mortgages
they could find let's put in this area
of Las Vegas where they're having huge
number of defaults let's put in this
part of Arizona where we know that the
brokers were actually engaged in fraud
let's go into Florida where we see that
the whole neighborhood is already you
know is unoccupied and they're never
going to pay off their mortgages so what
they did is there's this great case
called abacus this is all in government
documents we're literally the hedge fund
and Goldman Sachs colluded to create
something like this sold off the top row
to for a billion dollars to three large
institutions a billion dollars and the
hedge fund guy bet against it so if the
if those houses went to default the
hedge fund guy is going to win a billion
dollars what the people buying didn't
know was the hedge fund pick the
mortgages and what kind of mortgages do
you pick the worst ones you designed it
to fail so you can collect the insurance
I swear to god this happened the hedge
fund got a billion dollars goldman sachs
made its money by servicing the hedge
fund and selling it and the investors
lost a billion dollars now of course
this happened right the peak of the
housing market because people were
trying to unload the junk that they had
these securities that they had so this
was so every big bank started to play
this game with hedge funds design
something that's gonna fail and then
take out the insurance on it does that
sound crazy
oh they got there were all kinds of
kickbacks all they sought they and now
the question is when they did these tic
TOCs teams do you think it was legal
what was legal about this and what do
you think was illegal about this trip by
the way can you think of anywhere else
in our economy any place else where
you're allowed to produce something
that's going to fail so you can bet
against it can you think of it I mean if
you've tried to fix a horse race alright
bookies are not allowed to fix a horse
race accident where you try to collect
them you know you set up on it yeah
right that's called illegal sandy that's
illegal
now I'm trying to say is there any place
where it's legal okay I mean can you can
you guys go and wire something up so a
house so it's gonna burn up yeah I mean
I I mean you probably could figure out
how to do it I don't think I think you'd
go away they'd put you away right so so
it's it's probably not legal ah a lot of
these trading firms are also affiliated
with banks as well you said like JP
Morgan and Chase so you have to chase
supplying the mortgages knowing which
ones they're gonna fail you have JP
Morgan side which is doing like God you
know they didn't get caught doing quite
that but they that that would be
interesting if JP Morgan already told
the hedge fund these are our worst
mortgages want to put them in this fund
so it'll fail either faster that didn't
quite happen but what did happen is the
government came in and investigated and
they find Goldman Sachs five hundred
fifty million dollars in JP
organ 154 million and Citigroup 570
million for playing this game that's all
guess how much the hedge funds were
fined zero zero they got to keep all
their money by the way I wrote a piece
in Huffington Post where I suggested
that perhaps this was a bit of a slimy
thing and if these hedge fund people
were so smart why do they have to engage
in what I considered a near criminal
conspiracy guess what happened
they threatened to sue me the hedge
funds threatened to sue me for for being
involved in a near a near criminal
conspiracy they dropped the word near
now I I got this I actually it shook me
I got scared I said you know a billion
this was the richest of the hedge fund
guys right the number one the 2.4
million dollars an hour guys coming
after me so I'm thinking wait I didn't
say he was a criminal I said it was a
near criminal conspiracy and I'm
thinking what it's like nearly having
sex I mean isn't there a difference
between the two I think so if I remember
correctly there's a big difference yeah
if it is it let me know ok so I check
him down I went through the piece after
week and already had gotten like you
know 300,000 hits so I you know I got I
got the word out but I got scared can I
found out he was some phony publisher
was calling my agent to get a look at
the draft the next book this book and
then they wouldn't give their name so
I'm realizing ok now they're
investigating it there's a private
investigator on my tail because these
guys are touchy why are they so touchy
why do you think they're so touching
they know they're on the ethical edge
they know they skated right off to the
ethical edge and beyond but this is just
the start of it yeah good all those
banks that were fined Goldman Sachs
it's JPMorgan Chase so what were they
actually fine for what were they
excellent question yes no excellent
question they were fined for not fully
disclosing to their investors that the
hedge fund was handicapping the race
that's what they were fine for they
didn't fully disclose that the hedge
fund guy was picking the horses in the
race does that mean picking them picking
them to lose that that's so a full
disclosure laws but this is the only
place in capitalism the only place I can
think of where you're allowed to do this
you want to hear yeah bad Walmart takes
out life insurance policies on its
employees what you can make big money
they can take you ah
they do that on their executives
everybody know they've done everything
you should doing executives so example
the college probably has one on Dean
Merrill because he'd be absolutely
impossible to replace
so the hardship involved is is there let
me just move on here for a second I want
to ask you I've got that's just one
story of what they do uh you up for
another one uh yeah you know Jim Cramer
on Mad Money you ever see this guy on TV
yeah he's a riot right he's like a talks
faster than me and he used to run a
hedge fund and he ran it for ten years
and is his rate of return his percentage
return average was twenty three percent
a year every year so he writes this book
called confessions of a street junkie
Street addict or something and he
describes how he does it and it's it's
actually an entertaining book and it's
you know full of his woes and everything
else but it's not a confession he then
does an interview ten years later on a
website that he partially owns and he
says what he does and I read this thing
and I went oh my god this guy is saying
this stuff here's what he says you know
he works for CNBC right and he used to
be even when he ran his hedge fund he
used to appear in CNBC so what he would
do
what would you do if you're trying to
manipulate the market and you're on CNBC
have any ideas
let's see obviously how devious you
really can are yeah there you go lie
about the stock market but here's how he
lies about it he knows if he says it
yeah so he slips it to other reporters
he says I got a tip that you know
Google's got a problem with an
application and he he actually did it
about Apple because Apple never would
ever tell a reporter what he was doing
so if you slip false information to a
journalist there's no way for them to
check it so he would slip him little
things his own colleagues on CNBC they
would report it and then the stock he
was betting on it would either go up or
down based on that report and he
basically says in order to run a hedge
fund you have to lie he says that in the
center view but here's what he really
says he says if you're not willing to do
these things you shouldn't be in the
game whoa that's pretty amazing all
right you heard about insider trading
we now have 70 people behind bars
because what they do is they get a tip
on a stock before everybody else does
and they can make their bet it's that by
the way when people talk about Wall
Street as being a casino wrong word
casino there's a game of chance it's
regulated
there's odds everybody knows them and
you can win or lose when you're making
big money like this you don't want to
take a risk so you want that insider
information so there's no chance of you
losing it list goes on and on you have
to read the book the book is we're going
to stop for questions shortly the book
is designed for those of you who want to
make a million dollars an hour it's a 12
step guide we walk you through 12 steps
from rags to riches and if you have any
problems with this it'll also explain
some of the ethical problems that are
involved here anyway uh but this stuff
isn't just fun and games let me ask you
this let me let me close with a question
should we prevent this kind of
money-making if not why not it should
this should we let these hedge funds do
what they do like build products
designed to fail it's a free country
yes no what do you think yeah they can
cause companies to grow or crash whose
jobs lives and that's interesting well
here's what they say
don't worry that doesn't cause you any
problems I'm just taking money for some
other rich person you know that rich
person but who's paying for that yeah
good questions just another rich person
is to Wisconsin's whole district for
example where everybody's a bright
person who goes and buys this kind of
thing without anything behind it
excellent point
you know I excellent point
what are you going to get in the way
these rich people trying to you know
earn as much as they can
don't you want to earn as much as you
can you want somebody telling you not to
do it
efforts but the question would be is the
moral standpoint of it at what cost
alright let me talk about it what cost
now that you bring that up you know when
that when we saw the picture of the
stock market the housing market hitting
the top and then coming down that coming
down was accelerated dramatically on the
way up it was accelerated by that crazy
fantasy finance baseball game they were
playing on the way down it got
accelerated because imagine this if
there's one underlying mortgage and 20
different bonds are betting on one
underlying mortgage if it goes down the
20 bonds go down so when they said they
had junk you know toxic assets and all
that stuff all over the world they
really did it all came crashing down in
this game of betting designing things to
fail that accelerated the downward push
and you got this number of unemployed
people look at fairly steady from 2000
to 2008
boom when the game ended jumped up to
fourteen point three million people are
unemployed it will take over twelve
years at the current rate even I was I
make this estimate based on this last
month when the unemployment rate went
down and there were jobs created at that
rate it will take twelve years for us to
get back to where we were before the
crash
twelve years from today and hopefully
you know hopefully you guys will get
jobs and hang on to jobs yeah I think
everyone who lost their job during the
financial crisis needs to go hang out at
John Paulson's house and have him put
them up okay no names mentioned I don't
want to get sued again okay you're
talking - right - Kate Spaulding they
can sue me
okay great totally worth negative for my
student loans so so what are we so what
do we do what can we do you if you
wanted to bring some morality into this
situation some ethics what do you do
what can we do sure what would they say
what would hedge fund managers defenders
of Wall Street what would Bloomberg say
what's the value that they are bringing
to the economy chapter two step - oh we
have to read the book have to read the
book
now there's a whole cottage industry of
people that I call hedge fund
cheerleaders who claim that what they do
is is valuable as all of Silicon Valley
but the things that they say is there
the literally their defense of hedge
funds was that it that they they take on
risk that nobody else wants and they
stabilize the economic system how that
work first in 2008 in other words they
all this stuff about hedge fund
cheerleading was written in 2007 2006
and they claim they have a whole bunch
of claims that's just one of them they
stabilize the system they keep crashes
from happening they make the whole
system more flexible they make sure
there's money there when you want to buy
and sell stocks that you can always do
it there's they have a whole series of
things I go through each one of them in
one in Chapter two or three whatever it
is I go through each single one of them
and I think you'll find that their
claims are based on
wishful thinking really the only thing
they care about the only thing they care
about is squeezing out some profit
anybody here have an e trade account
anybody invest any money anywhere okay
keep it by the top we you know when you
press the button to buy something before
that trade goes through there are a
group of hedge funds called
high-frequency traders who buy the stock
faster than you do and sell it back to
you for a few pennies more and pocket
the difference every single time not
electronically with these high-frequency
computers that are located right next to
the Wall Street exchange they make from
five to twenty billion dollars a year
doing that now I've got now tell me what
good that does you that's the question
and I try to explore all those questions
in the book they have believe me there
are hundreds of arguments that they make
in their behalf but when you push on
them you realize that they're in
business for one reason only right
they're going to make as much money as
they can anyway they can expect and try
not to get caught yes we have to have
rules like if you mate
if you want to make profit from the
American economy you have to you have to
give a pledge of some kind of economical
responsibility we have to reinvest in
the in the country engine it's a good
point I realized smiling it's an
excellent point the reason I'm smiling
is that there was this a in the Harvard
Business Review of this business
psychologist this woman from UCLA writes
an article about why she thinks hedge
funds do what they do and she comes up
with this world
she calls it cryogenic that basically
the atmosphere of working a hedge fund
encourages you to break the law and we
every which way you can
so there have to be sea change for the
morality you're talking about to take
place so question is how do we get there
my question is why is it possible for
them to do
this when you have companies or
industries like pharmaceutical
industries who sell drugs for inflated
prices and when the government finds out
with all the side-effects and all the
you know the FCC and all these other
instruments come into play they get
regulated they get bumped down they get
sideswiped and generic you know brands
come out and so on and so forth but
these guys they can't make generic
brands of money and financial
institutions it's like you either roll
with them or you shut it all down
well that when when we took our let me
give you just a little bit of history
you can understand how we got here again
1929 there was a stock market crash and
we found out at that time that Wall
Street firms were manipulating the stock
market you know inflating stock prices
doing all kinds of stuff so we regulated
the hell out of them starting in the
1930s we put our foot on Wall Street saw
those two lines of their wages and
everybody else's were the same we made
Wall Street a boring place to work but
then when we took our foot off in the
mid 1970s 1980s the game that this whole
game started again and basically the
genies out of the bottle so the question
becomes how do you put it back in how do
you reregulate they're very strong now
one of these guys is given a hundred
million dollars to Central Park another
is given a hundred million dollars to
the public library here in New York how
do you how do you how do you get the
genie back in the bottle yeah why don't
you start with creating awareness you
know don't awareness I think would you
explain to us today's is my new compared
to you know what it should be and then
the American public would start fighting
back and it feels started to happen for
a while we had Occupy Wall Street there
was a point where we were starting to
like say well you know what maybe they
should pay us back for the damage they
did let me give you one since we're
getting now near to the end involved
Mike does not want to pay me overtime
it's a million and a half
oh wait it's after after six o'clock I'm
sorry it's double time two million okay
there's a thing called a financial
transaction tax or a financial
speculation tax and it's a it's there's
ten countries in Europe that are doing
this now which is they put a little tax
on every single stock bond funny money
and she's instruments all these fancy
finance things they put a little tax on
every time they're bought and sold and
what if the tax were big enough I made
one calculation catch this it could
provide enough money could be generated
to provide free tuition for every
student in the country going to a public
college or university no more debt so
this is a big deal and they're scared to
do it it wipes out high-frequency
trading because they're going to make a
few pennies out of all of you they're
collecting a hidden tax this makes the
tax overt so there's a there's a very
that's a big one you could we could
prohibit high-frequency training there's
a loophole by the way oh I forgot to
tell you this oh not only that they make
all that money the billions of the
billionaire the million dollars an hour
but they pay less tax than you do
because they have a special loophole
called carried interest where they can
only think it was fifteen percent now
it's twenty percent so the top rate so
they have a tax loophole that they're
hanging on for dear life and we're
talking about sequestering and austerity
and that tax loophole still makes it
through and there's a good case we made
it we should limit the size of these
hedge funds so they can't can't be so
big just say it can't be bigger than a
certain a certain amount but the bottom
line comes out to this that none of this
happens nothing happens no morality as
you said is going to be brought in
unless we do something about it and you
all are actually one day may end up
being leaders in your Union and in your
community and it's going to be up to up
to you I'm all getting a little longer
than
I don't know that I'm going to be around
to see it but the game won't change
until you force it to change and it
starts with awareness as you said but
then it's going to start then we're
going to have to make some demands and
force it I believe on both political
parties so so we're all union members
and from everything we're hearing it
seems like this activity is against our
best interest so what do you think how
should we how much force should we use
to to change the situation and improve
our economy and improve the way money is
distributed in the United States what do
people think how do you bet against them
they've been against us how do you beg
except oh it's how you think respond to
that how do we bet against them how do
we change you know the odds put them
more in our favor can we start a
petition to the branch of government
that's from charge sounds like a good
idea what else designing a system that
can make the critical but I'm sorry
design a system that can make them feel
and collect on them oh yes for wisely
just for wise what convinced you to do
I'm like you're some cheese mother faces
here you're jumping in what else goes
into a headphone other stuff they can do
whatever they want to do they can buy
companies they can buy bonds they can
buy bets upon debts you see we click on
the entry they're usually two cents or
something on that full weave and get
that big group but if you buy a piece of
real estate I just think they're all I'm
just thinking that what else goes into
it they benefit from how do you I focus
every want something else where that
stuff yeah I'm not let me let me just
make this one point I don't think
there's any way we can outplay them at
their own game i I think it becomes
quite its political it the it's the
rules of the game that allowed them to
get going in other words when you
regulate they can't play this game and
you deregulate they can play this game
so it's a question of how of whether you
want more regulations and how to get
them yes right away just like everything
else
nice and how to send letters to help
people you have to send letter she
represented with you
regulation it's just like all the things
that have fallen by the way said in the
last 20 30 years the unions and people
standing together a phone by the way
said because something like this is
allowed to happen because people are
allowed to stand up for their own good
disregarding the good of the people
around them and because people have
become lazy to stand out on the corner
and and protest in France for example
they process at the drop of a hat he
says they're going to change a couple
words in a law and 50,000 people will
come out and protest against it maybe
it's a little overdone over here but
over here it's under done but yeah it
takes unity it takes people standing
together it takes me beginning a group
of people and writing a letter to your
Congressman writing 50 letters to
congressmen getting on Facebook and
putting it up there and letting people
know that it's something that you're
interested in yeah now is it laziness or
is it our own greed that doesn't allow
us to go out there and actually strike
or show our unity together for example
nowadays we have you know a lot of
people talking about the gasoline strike
that's coming up soon or something like
that and it's all on social media but
people don't do it though people don't
want it you know a strike gas they don't
want to go out there and take a day off
of work they don't want to take those
days off to show the unity that we
really do have so a lot of times our own
greedy that doesn't allow us to show
what we want to do what we want what we
really want exactly unions have lost
power like one side of the coin and
we're not looking at the other side and
that's that we have our government
that's allowing this to happen and a lot
of these officials are bought through
campaign funds and stuff like that so
sometimes you have to actually start
from the root and say you know how the
disk allowed others gettable is allowed
to happen and that started like you said
through deregulation and how did that
happen that was our government officials
learning these things going to effect
that allowed them to get out of control
so maybe we should start at the room
that that I'll focus me more on our
government putting things back into
place that kept them on the control for
so long that's a very good point man
over here
thing on all the unit members should
have this question read this book could
let more people to understand the game
than then from your lips to God's ears
tonight there's going to be a conference
call with Governor Cuomo who's
supporting campaign public financing for
all state government elections in New
York State like we have in New York City
public financing of Elections to limit
the influence of real estate and Wall
Street in elections and that's actually
something that we can directly get
involved in as citizens in New York
State to help lead the way in the
country to limit what Juan was talking
about money in elections
let me make one observation here we put
a couple things together
when that hedge fund guy came after me
was it was an interesting thing because
it reflected something that I hadn't
thought about before which is how could
they be so touching what are they
worried about hey if I just made a
billion dollars on a deal and I didn't
get prosecuted why would I care what a
two-bit blogger says about me I mean you
know I'm not exactly in the New York
Times every week what I realized was
what they're worried about is a popular
uproar against them they're worried that
something like Occupy Wall Street is
going to happen because this happened
before Occupy Wall Street when I wrote
the article they're worried that a bunch
of people are going to go to the streets
and demand their heads on a platter and
they're worried that that could really
change things they're more worried about
change then we are about making it I
mean they have more cop they're afraid
that we can do more than we think we can
do so it makes me think that they're
vulnerable
the other thing I just want you want to
point out to you I don't know if you
remember this before Occupy Wall Street
hit down the street here the country was
talking about austerity and the grant
there was all this talk in Washington
about austerity Occupy Wall Street hits
the whole conversation changes to the 1%
the 99% Wall Street the whole
conversation changed as soon as Occupy
Wall Street disappeared
now we're talking about austerity again
so there's power and it makes me think
the next time something like Occupy Wall
Street happens we better be there
because there's a lot of power there how
to build it that's why you got people
like Sandhya she'll help us do that
okay sorry I just want to say something
about voting it's real important and
especially like not just like the big
ones like we have a big one and it was
end up in a dressing room okay not
noches around not to me do you know
right now okay
not just a big ones like presidential
elections but you know these congressmen
who get elected in the two years in
between who wall street lobbies to turn
back their little no fees for taxes on
their on the money that they get we need
to not elect them that coming up for
reelection we need to not vote for them
and vote for people who are going to
take care of working people's interests
and the other side you know the the
people who buy the homes and get ripped
off by these banks and these companies
and we can do something in power we just
need to do it
it's gotta people want interested
because what you were saying about the
guy coming after you had the what the
hedge fund manager I think not that he
was just afraid of an uproar and you
turning into a million people I think
one thing that he did that most people
on the other side are not doing is he's
exercising his right he has the right to
come after you
he has a right and he's using it whether
he's afraid or not he's got money he
doesn't care what he wants to intimidate
you by saying you know what I can do
this and I'm gonna do it got my
attention you know if we all
collectively got together as people and
we did the same exact thing because we
can nobody can stop
from having a rally you know or any
other function you know at the end of
the day we can do whatever it is we need
to do to make it happen
the problem with us most of us is either
we don't have the information we don't
have the finance or we're just afraid
because we're going against a million
dollar guy or billion dollar guy good
point
the last time our country was as such an
economic disparity was during the Great
Depression of 1929 right before it
before the Great right before the Great
Depression you know which led to the New
Deal you said a series of like
government programs designed to create
jobs and reform the financial sector and
kickstart you know the economy you know
based on economy today do you think this
meant like the new New Deal well you
know I
I've been struggling with this question
which is why has been why is the
response been so different after this
crash compared to 1929 because we it's
very disturbing
so after 1929 pretty much we jumped in
guess you know I would say back then a
lot more people paid attention to what
happened around them whereas now it can
be very easily distracted with stuff
that we have around us I mean you know
um just it's very easy to just also I
feel like there's you know a lot more
people that live these days
back in the day it's like it was it was
harder to get away with this background
that is now that's an interesting point
it could have been more severe back then
too because now we have unemployment
insurance you know Medicare Medicaid we
have this protection yeah we also live
in a financial system where back then
after a Great Depression you didn't have
money and you didn't have there's no way
for you to get food so you were it was a
very real you know you were hungry
literally and figuratively but them now
we have we have a debt based you know
financial system where you not even
though we know that it's wrong and we
know at the end of the day everyone here
could still get what they want and that
you you're you're procuring like you
know make believe that no one's really
hungry like they were back in the 30s
and then the seventies are in the
contest where we're right there so I
definitely some truth that we have time
for one more question
yes I'm just going to say that speaking
to the debt based society that it's it's
government that's actually set the
example for that I mean look at our
deficit and it is an illusion we're
basically living on this cloud of
illusion and I think maybe that's why it
has an effective Asst the way it had in
the earlier in last century is because
we have this illusion that everything's
okay you go home your TV turns on it's
all good
because you go to sleep you get up in
the morning you go to work and you can
just use your credit card the next day
if you don't have cash handy it's an
illusion
but when it falls apart what's going to
happen then unfortunately the way it
looks is it until that falls apart not
much is going to be done about it
because people continue to live in this
illusion or how many people don't have
$20,000 debt in their back pocket now
whatever you know it's it's it's school
debt or I'll pay it off eventually but
it's it's there and it's a fact that
we're all living in debt and until
somebody says you know this is immoral
this is not the way to live until one of
those countries starts collecting
against our government I don't think
much is going to be done about it well
we should do another whole workshop on
that just to leave it guess how much of
the China guess how much did the China
of our whole day guess how much China
homes owns of our dental Haiti any other
guesses 8% guess who owns most of our
debt we do